just as a pastor pastor jesse i'm trying
to understand do you do you do you uh
believe that the bible has been changed
because you alluded to the fact that
maybe something was taken out of the
quran but the quran is the verbatim word
of god almighty tamper-free temper proof
that's one of the miracles of the quran
that we have it today as it was
preserved we have it and anyone who
comes at it objectively scientifically
analytically and they approach it
they'll see there's no way this can come
from anyone other than the creator that
has on earth but let me tell me do you
believe the bible because i heard you
say it i want to just hear from you do
you believe the bible has been tampered
with has been changed because you know
as a pastor that matthew didn't write
matthew luke didn't write luke it's
according to matthew according to luke
and no credible bible scholar will tell
you that matthew wrote matthew so that's
the leading question
okay so how would you yes or no is the
bible been changed i'll just do like i
may i'll do like you do
as the
has the bible belongs now due to years
yeah help us understand jesse men have
rewritten the bible in order to fit in
with the culture
rather than making the culture fit in
with what's right they have changed
about the wordings of the bible that's
why god not the only reason but one of
the reasons god put the spirit upon our
heart we have a teacher within
and that is the holy spirit and that's
why god said let no man teach you
because if another man teaches you
they're going to intellectually teach
you right into hell
but if you hear what they have to say
let it pass through one through one ear
and out the other but allow only the
holy spirit to teach you you cannot go
wrong
so how do you decipher now
so if i understood you correctly that
you do agree that the bible's been
changed
how does someone decipher what's the
word of god like there's many passages
that are really clear and lucid where dr
sabil was mentioning that the passage of
hero israel the lord thy god is one you
know that jesus being subordinate to god
that he prayed to god we would say those
are in line with what we believe that
jesus was worshiping the creator calling
people away from idol worship away from
immorality we'd agree but then you have
other passages in there that we would
disagree with like the passages that
paint some of the prophets is committing
immoral acts and whatnot we would say
this is the hands of man this is not to
disrespect you as a christian or
anything but we would say that this is
like because you said you said this is
the bible's been changed and and if it's
changed people are adding deleting so
this is where we would say and take
strong offense when they insult many of
the gods prophets and messengers and
they attribute things vices to them sins
to them that we would say there's no way
because the prophets are perfect well
apparently the quran has been changed
too because it was definitely in there
where it says christians and jews are
infidel worthy of death
and that you can lie to them you could
be free
we're doing it again
jesse where you going we did this yeah
so so just like apparently
it sounds like the quran has been
rigorous
so has the bible been rewritten and is
set up to deceive the people and not to
set them free but to control them
so brother jesse uh historically we know
and i can show you the evidence that the
bible that you're assumed that you are
also acknowledging has been changed new
testament and old testament right but
that process did not happen to the quran
from the time the quran was given to
prophet muhammad peace be upon him from
god he memorized the whole quran he had
it written down
thousands and millions of people all
throughout the ages they memorized the
whole quran and we have the copies of
the quran going all the way back to the
first generation so the quran has not
been changed because allah god promises
in the quran that god will protect it so
the question
tells me that it's not there about
infidels the christians and jews and
what you could lie to them to see them
you could feed them
was not whatever
now maybe that has been taken out i
won't argue that because i haven't i
haven't seen the new quran i just saw
the real ones where those things were
there
and so they may have been changed they
may not be there today because
um
i've noticed that when the muslim move
into the christian world
western society their whole mission is
to destroy the western society to
destroy christianity so maybe that has
been changed
are you really do you really believe the
stuff that you're saying jesse
are you happy all the time what no
so so jesse
you know i also you know
to spread good and forbid evil uh to uh
like i said to hate injustices you know
to be just so how can we like it's it's
a contradiction it's it doesn't make
sense jesse we don't see the muslim out
there denouncing
they're not they're not out there
denouncing that christian the quran is
wrong
where are the muslims i don't see
numbers a muslim denouncing that at all
jesse jesse do you see christians
denouncing hallelujah
who is hallelujah
[Laughter]
do you see the christians denying any
passage of the bible
what does that have to do with the quran
the muslim not denouncing that
christians and jews are infidels and
worthy of death
so okay so me as a muslim i will not
deny
that what you're saying because the
quran does not say it to begin with it's
not even there in the quran whether
jesse
may be rewritten so no no
no
people have memorized the whole quran
suppose if somebody comes and adds
something to the quran for example there
are millions of memorizers out there
they will catch it they will correct it
they will throw this copy out if
somebody adds something to it and that
process is a check and balance process
that you will not find for the bible for
the old new testament the quran has a
dual check and balance system so what we
have in our hands the arabic quran is
exactly the same that was given by god
to prophet muhammad peace be upon him it
has not been changed later on maybe in a
different episodes we can go over the
process how the quran has been protected
by god zero change
not a single letter not a single word
not a single chapter but let me ask you
this question
why do i believe in the passages that
you are mentioning from the bible that
man is the head of the household or head
of his wife the bible doesn't say that
the man is the head of the household the
bible says that the husband is the head
of the wife
and because you might be ahead of your
wife you are afraid to say that you're
ahead of your wife because you know
what's going on
so so jesse why should you believe in
that man
okay
why would you why
no hold on brother why should you
believe in that because that maybe
somebody changed it somebody inserted
that since bible has been changed why
should i risk my life of eternity in a
book that is less than 100 percent yeah
don't risk your life like that because i
don't want your wife to hurt you when
you try to be the man